Britain and France are routinely
condemned for their appeasement of
Hitler and Mussolini in the years
leading up to the second world war they
saw Britain and France too little to
combat growing Italian and German
aggression during the mid to late 1930s
it's argued that appeasement allowed the
two fascist powers to grow in strength
for made World War two inevitable
furthermore it's also said that it
needlessly condemned millions of
Europeans to live under regimes that
they did not want to the big question is
did appeasement actually work and
achieve what the Allies wanted before
continuing it's very important to note
that the governments of France and the
UK weren't free to take his harder line
as they wanted to their respective
populations were fiercely against any
future war in Britain specifically was
suffering from economic malaise which
was combined with the simple fact its
power was now waning relative to Germany
as such both nations had militaries
which were underfunded and fixing their
problems would take many years so the
first major act of appeasement came when
Hitler publicly announced the
reintroduction of conscription in 1935
which had been forbidden in the Treaty
of Versailles the British prime minister
Ramsay MacDonald didn't want to denounce
the German decision lest they withdraw
from talks over limiting the size of
their Navy the next problem came with
the Italian War and subsequent conquest
of Ethiopia was Britain didn't want a
stronger Italian Empire they realized
that militarily they weren't able to do
much about it France took the lead here
and pressured Britain not to pursue too
strong a response
France is thinking here was that if
Italy felt too isolated it would turn to
Germany for an alliance and that
couldn't be allowed in early 1936
Germany Rhee militarized the Rhineland
meaning that it's stationed troops there
which was something also forbidden by
the Treaty of Versailles the French had
a larger and more capable army at this
point and could have quite easily
defeated the German troops there but
political problems at home stopped any
interference Europe was pretty quiet for
a couple of years until early 1938 when
Germany annexed Austria and Hitler
subsequently turned his attention to
Czechoslovakia specifically this land
the Sudetenland which was populated
mostly by ethnic Germans and which
Hitler then demanded be given to him the
British in the French were in a bit of a
conundrum here because they wanted to
guarantee the independence of
Czechoslovakia but they also knew that
military intervention wouldn't have
stopped Germany from conquering it as
such the Munich conference was held
which saw British Prime Minister Neville
Chamberlain Mussolini Hitler and the
French prime minister
Eduardo Xavier come to an agreement it
was decided that Czechoslovakia would
cede the Sudetenland that Germany would
promised not to conquer the rest of it
until it did in March of 1939
the reason for throwing Czechoslovakia
to the Germans was that both France and
Britain knew that militarily they
weren't able to fight yet you see the
Allies weren't fools they didn't believe
that one day Hitler would be happy and
stop eating countries they simply knew
that some would have to be sacrificed to
buy them time to rearm when Italy
invaded and conquered Albania in April
of 1939 the French decided that there
could be no more appeasement instead a
pre-emptive war would be necessary to
protect Greece and contain Mussolini and
went alladia brought his plan to the
British their response was agreement
just kidding more appeasement in fact
Chamberlain asked France to consider
ceding colonial territory to the
Italians in order to placate Mussolini
and tried to dissuade him from joining
Germany in the war France said no to
this in both allies largely accepted
that a war with Germany would mean a war
with Italy at this point of course
appeasement couldn't last forever and
when Poland with British and French
guarantees refused to cede territory to
Germany it did the Second World War
kicked off and to many this is proof
that appeasement failed miserably this
assumes that appeasement was meant to
prevent war which was not the Allies
intention it was supposed to allow
Britain and France to rearm which they
both did British defense spending rose
rapidly during the five years leading up
to the war with the government spending
40% of the national budget on defense
after disa debt and land crisis and as
for France they used the time to
massively increase naval spending there
was however one major flaw in
sacrificing other countries to allow for
more time to rearm it allowed germany in
italy to continue their military buildup
and frankly these two use their time
much more effectively than either France
or Britain did I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to my patrons that you see
on screen now and a special thanks to
James Bissonnette party boy Coe Ozark a
flash chris wicker Rob Waterhouse
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan Maggie
packs Kowski Winston k-word rafail Adam
Harvey Anthony Beckett Skye Chappell and
the amusement park Ives
you